Double Dribble, the ball is in your court, and it's time to play a little 5 on 5.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Joe.
And I'm Sean.
Guys, we are in the thick of September.
And I'm not talking about September our year.
I'm talking about September 1987.
15 games this month on the NES in September of 1987.
I think it's safe to say that this NES thing is going to be a hit and that the games are finally, you know, like the floodgates are opened.
That's a lot of games, Mike.
It's a lot of games. I think even now, 2018 or 2019, depending where you're listening to it, it's still up in the air.
I don't know whether the NES will take off.
Like, again? Not just at all.
I don't know if we have enough data yet.
He's right. I mean, they haven't released a game for that system in a long time.
Right.
You can get like, you know, a brand new NES updated version of Jeopardy because there's a plug and play Jeopardy.
You can just get that and have it.
And it's a it's a whole new ROM and things to play.
I don't know if we're going to do them on this chronological exploration.
Do they have the Nintendo seal of approval?
They don't. OK.
And I don't even know if Nintendo knows that they're doing it.
I hope they'll listen to this podcast.
It's just a fun thing I had to bring up.
But guys, Konami is Konami Konami.
I say Konami, but I don't know.
I like Konami. Konami is at it again.
And this time they're tackling a different sport.
That sport. Basketball.
And what sport before that?
Track and field. It's just a little pop quiz.
It's been a little while.
They did track and field, which came out in April of 87.
So it's been just a few months and they're ready to try another sport.
And I got to say, I liked what I saw out of track and field.
I definitely thought that that sport game was competent, competent, unlike some Nintendo releases.
It's true. Games. So this came out.
Double Dribble is a name that you recognize or what?
Like, do you guys recognize that Double Dribble name?
I don't like I don't expect it to be a video game.
Like I had not heard of this game.
Got it. I've heard of this game from a Nirvana, the band, the show video that you showed me.
Oh, yes. The only place that I've heard of it.
Yes. That one.
Everybody should go check that out.
I'll put that in the show notes.
Maybe if someone reminds me, if I don't put in the show notes, just call me.
I'll be like, hey, where's that link?
And I that goes for anything I've ever done where I can say, I'm going to go.
I'm going to give you a little bit of a deal.
Call out anything he's ever done. Just call me out.
Um, but don't call me out on what I did in fourth grade.
That was legal.
Uh, so Double Dribble came out in the arcade first in 1986.
So not that much of a gap between the arcade version and the NES version.
But I just thought that before we talked too much about the NES version of the game, I had
to mention while I was researching the arcade version of this game that it has honestly crazier
microtransactions than today's games.
You serious? And not in the sense of like that kind of microtransactions, but just like it, like the way that it artificially
inflate your time into putting money into the games is where you keep playing it.
So the arcade version was actually like, it was timed.
So after every minute of play, the game was owed a credit.
If the score was either tied or the computer is ahead.
So if after one minute of play, if you were beating the computer, you got a free minute,
you know, but every minute that you were behind, you'd have to pay for.
So do you have to just like try and, and, uh, balance playing the game and rustling through
your pocket? No, it would pause.
It would just stop at the end of that minute.
So many average players could earn, um, like, you know, maybe the first minute for free,
but every minute becomes, they up the CPU.
It would be harder.
I think it was going to get more expensive for every minute.
Like that would have been, actually, that would have been better.
That's because what they actually wind up doing by making the CPU harder and harder every single
minute, it, it's like they make it to the point where a three point shot is virtually impossible
for you. Like you can't get three point three pointers anymore.
You can only go for two and slam dunks, which will fail more often.
Probably. Yeah. They'll fail more often.
It's basically just like designed so that after 10 minutes, you're going to get locked
out of this game. You will have to pay again to keep going.
Well, that's a, that's capitalism.
Yeah. And, uh, it's no surprise, I guess that that comes from Konami.
Konami. They don't care about you and they let you know it.
Does that, does that difficulty at least like reset once you've paid and it's like,
okay, now you get a couple more easier.
You know, that part I couldn't figure out.
It seemed to not change.
It seems to only change if you like start from zero again.
You know, it's, it, which is funny that you mentioned that because yeah, it's still cost
the same amount to keep going.
So it's like, you might as well just play the first minute every single time.
And then if you have to pay, you might as well just walk away from the machine and start
over. All right.
So we can, we can talk about the game now.
All right. Uh, anybody want to talk about how basketball works?
Okay. Yeah. Um, so I'd like to start by saying that it's strange that this game is named after like
a foul. Like you're not supposed to double dribble.
Double dribble though. For me does, it sounds cool.
Yeah. I mean like it's got alliteration.
It's no NBA jam.
No, like it doesn't sound like I'm about to have the time of my life, but it definitely
doesn't sound like I'm committing a foul.
It sounds like I'm actually like doing something cool when it says double dribble.
I mean, you are, uh, if you're double dribbling.
Um, but I would say that it definitely has, uh, all the rules of basketball.
Okay. For the most part.
And this is our first basketball game on the NES too.
No one else has tackled this yet.
And I don't know if that's because basketball at the time wasn't as popular as the other
sports. Uh, we still, it was still pretty popular.
Yeah. We still haven't seen hockey.
Uh, so, you know, I think it's just interesting to notice like which games are coming up because
we've already had skiing.
Yeah. Well, you know, like what we're northerners, we're going to be, uh, we're going to be more
towards hockey. I mean, hockey didn't even blow up in, uh, in the South until at least like they had all
those expansion teams and that was for a while.
Yes. Yeah. And anyway, we're not talking about hockey and, um, it's, it's interesting that they
have, uh, that they have some of the big cities, um, that they, and their team colors,
they approximate team logos and colors.
Yeah. This was kind of like how, um, uh, NES baseball, which is haunted, um, that, that game had,
uh, if you were playing the North American version, it had like letters to correspond to
teams, but they couldn't, you know, they couldn't license that out and they didn't license it out
here either. Those licenses were expensive.
So they said, screw it. We'll just call the team Boston.
No need for Celtics.
You know, there was a Boston team, but, uh, you know what I'm saying?
Like there was a New York team, right?
Yes. Yeah. And they were blue LA Chicago.
Yep. But when we're actually talking about the game and how the game plays is entirely broken.
Okay. And would you, would you like to cat and start that off?
Um, sure.
I mean, so I think like the biggest problem with the game, we can't get into it.
We can get to in a bit, but, um, you start the game by doing a tip off and, uh, regardless
of, uh, like how you w you should actually like do a tip off.
It's always go second because, um, if the first guy will pick the ball out of the air
and then you just jump and rip it out of his hands.
And that's just how it works as one does.
Yeah. As one does in basketball.
Um, then, uh, you, you, you, you try your hardest to get up into a shooting range and,
um, then you just go into the top right corner and, uh, shoot a three and you will always
win. That is the strategy.
You know, there, it takes some, it takes a lot of time, I guess, to find that spot by
your own. Like if you go on game FAQ, you'll find it right away.
But like, you know, it takes time to figure that out.
But I think that ruins my favorite thing about this game, which is that, that jump timing
mechanic, you know, of like being able to like, kind of have a moment where it's like, if you
release the ball right here, it'll be, it'll be, it'll go in, but only because you're at
this distance from the net, you know, and it's like the closer you are, the less you
have to jump and the further back you are.
But once you figure out that perfect spot, it's almost like, it's just how fast can I
get there? How did you guys figure out that perfect spot?
I don't know. Well, I found it out through game FAQ, you know, that's why I'm saying like, it takes
time to feel like when I was playing by myself just against the computer, I was actually losing
pretty badly. So my, my thing was how do I get better?
So I went on the game FAQ and I didn't try to abuse that too much.
Cause I actually found that like, if, if you can steal the ball, you know, I'm
like, that's the best strategy because they'll never score as long as you know how to properly
steal the ball.
Yeah. I could only win a game by the three pointer exploit.
I didn't know about the three pointer exploit.
Yeah. I only found out about it because, you know, I played it a couple of times and I was like,
okay, I'll, I'll, I'll check and see what other people have, have, have said about this
game. And I saw that there was a, like a family guy clip.
Yes. Uh, they play a double dribble on family guy.
And it, you know, it's weird.
It's the actual, it's the actual, it's the actual great.
Yeah. It's like the graphics and everything.
Like, yeah, well it's, it's actually, I think they stole it off of YouTube.
Wow. And they never credited the guy.
That's so bizarre.
Um, they don't do the three point trick though.
Do they do the three point?
Oh my goodness. That's how I found out about it.
That is so funny.
They comment like, Hey, you can't do that corner shot.
And I guess it's the only way you can play this game like with a friend and be somewhat
fair. Just like, okay, we will do a gentleman's agreement to not do the corner shot.
Cause I was very surprised when you said it was, this game is really broken because I didn't
think so at all, but I didn't know about that.
Is there another reason you thought it was broken or?
Um, the fact that there's only one, like there's only one, uh, strategy for the tip off and
the stealing the ball thing.
Stealing is kind of lucky. Stealing.
You have to be, you have to be in front of the other person, which I thought was weird.
You can't do it from behind, but once you're in front of them, like that's the whole objective
of when they have the ball is just like run in front of them as fast as you can hit
the steal button. It's going to work.
It's not like there's a percentage odds thing, you know, it's like, as long as you are in
the proper spot, you're going to steal the ball from them.
Um, so once I figured out how to do that, even the game got easier, you know, it's even,
it's a little difficult though, because there's no variety in like running speed.
So if you're behind him, you're always going to be behind him.
Sure. But I mean, like, you know, if the way the team is struck, you can select which player
you control, which I thought was great that you can do that.
Uh, that we haven't really seen that.
Yeah. That worked pretty well being able to change a guy.
Um, yeah, I thought that like compared to any other team sport game we've played so far,
I think this has worked the best.
I think we, yeah, we all remember volleyball.
Yeah. Like they butchered.
I think that volleyball. Yeah.
Volleyball is definitely the worst when it comes to, uh, being able to, to select a specific
player. How did soccer do?
I think that soccer was one of the better ones.
I think that soccer is still like the most polished, like team sport game I've played.
I mean, yes. Okay. Um, were you guys impressed at all by the accuracy of the game?
Like to get all the rules down.
We played so many of these sports games that like a lot of the rules are either like missing
or they're half baked or there's only some enforced.
Like I'm not sure if there was a shot clock.
Mm hmm. Um, I think that maybe it's something that I wasn't paying attention to because it's kind
of hard not to take a shot within 24 seconds.
Um, I think that it's really easy to foul like just inexplicably.
I noticed that too.
Just like I had to like run by someone.
Yeah. Oh, you got pushing.
Yeah. And, uh, I never was followed upon very often.
I think I got, I think I got a couple free throws.
So we're, we're in the camp of not that accurate.
I would say it's like, it's got some stuff going, going forward and some stuff not so much.
It feels like for, for an NES game of this time, it feels like it pretty good.
Well, I'm thinking, yeah, exactly.
I'm thinking follows the rules of the sport.
Well, accuracy missing, you know?
And I think that's, that is possible.
That makes sense. You know, it's like, it's one thing to get the fouls, but it's not.
It's like the accuracy of how the fouls are given.
I mean, like if you do a, you will get a backcourt violation, like that's in the game.
Like it's they're there, but it's a, it's, it's poorly executed in some points.
Uh, guys, are there enough choices in this game for variety?
I mean, you got four teams, three levels of single play difficulty and four choices of quarter lengths.
Is that enough? I think that it like, what else would you want?
No, I I'm saying that in a way that sounds negative, but I guess, you know, if you're
asking if I'm answering my own question, I do think that's enough.
I think that's actually a lot more choices than we're used to.
It is. I don't think everyone is going to feel like this, but the way that I would play a game
like this and the way I think that is the best way for me to play it is play it against
the computer. Whatever.
Half a dozen times get the, get the hang of it, whatever, just, and then forever.
That would just be a game I would play against a friend.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I agree.
And also I would, these kinds of games, these arcadey sports games, I tend to have the, um,
the timeline to the shortest possible.
So it's like, you know, that game's over.
Let's do another one. You know, um, something I, something I was going to say with the quarter lengths though, I
we haven't really had that in too many other sports games.
I mean, I would have loved in NES baseball to be like, this one's just going to be a
three inning game. You know?
Yeah. Nine inning obligation is way too long for that game.
That game overstays its welcome in its own nine inning game.
Yeah. Was the cut scene for the dunk.
Okay. There's a cut scene for when you dunk the ball and it's, there's two variations too, right?
There's like one where your arm leaps forward.
And then there's one where it's like a backwards dunk.
Backwards dunk. Yeah. But you don't shatter the glass.
Yeah. But in the, in the manual, I think it says something like to dunk, press this and then
sit back and enjoy the movie.
The movie. The three frames.
It says that in the manual?
It says like something along the lines of like, and then, then enjoy the, you know,
I don't know what they say.
They might say movie, but.
No, that's great. I just, I thought that was super cool.
I enjoyed that touch.
I, I, I'm also sort of wondering though, because you can fail a dunk and you'll just hear this
very, uh, unpleasant, like sound of it bouncing off the rim.
And I just want to know, like, well, how did they calculate that?
Like, is it just RNG or did you just approach it wrong?
Cause they will play the movie.
Yeah. Ends with.
Brr. Oh, really?
I didn't know. I thought with the movie played, it meant that you know, no, I've like computer failed
several times for me.
Yeah. I, I, and I thought one thing that was interesting with the dunk too, is that I noticed that
I missed, I missed dunks more when I was trapped, when I was running like too aggressively
at the net.
Like if I was running up to it and then dunking like late that that would happen.
So maybe it was just an idea that like, as I was approaching it, I didn't quite land the
ball in the net.
Yeah. Like, you know, that could just be my mind, you know, getting playful and being like,
Oh, that's why it happened. Instead, you know, that's why it happened.
Not because the game just decided you don't deserve that point.
We're going to just bounce it out anyway.
I think, uh, you guys can tell me that you saw it, but I think this might be arcade
only if you in the arcade one, if you take a jump shot, there's also a chance for a cut
scene. I never saw that.
I never saw that either.
So I'm going to list that as arcade only, but I did check out the cut scene, um, on YouTube.
Yeah. And I mean like, you know, it's just as, it's just a jump shot grainy and pixely as the
other one, but it still looks cool.
I think those moments make you make it feel cool.
No. Yeah. I think it adds flair.
It's a, I mean, it's, it's not quite as, uh, uh, uh, a heckin awesome as, uh, having
a ball set on fire in NBA jam, but like that NBA jam wouldn't be NBA jam without it's really
weird over the top parts.
Mm. Um, but, uh, yeah, I think that this game at its core has a lot going for it.
And then just like a lot of stuff on the, on the periphery sort of, uh, makes it jank.
And this game needed music too, during the game.
Like, uh, I, I feel like there was something there, but I think they were like trying to
do like the, the squeaks.
Right. Exactly. And I'm like, okay, sure.
Like that's, that's enough.
But like the game wasn't fully, you know, immersed in realism to begin with.
So just put a fun track under that.
Like that would have been fine.
Maybe they were worried.
Like how we've complained about some other games where it's like, if the music track is just
a woman and looping thing, you're going to get tired of it.
And they did have a pretty good track in that halftime show.
Oh my God. That stood out to me.
I was like, that sound, this is actually like a good track just for this, like one little
halftime show that happens in between.
Any, apparently any sports game that has a halftime show is great.
You know, like we loved soccer.
That was crazy.
Is soccer the only one that's had one so far?
Did volleyball have one?
I'm trying to think about if volleyball had one.
I don't remember.
I know that. Tennis definitely did not.
Yeah. But no, it's the same thing.
You know, like they're a little better rendered in this one in terms of like the shape of
a person. Right.
They're not ET looking figures like in soccer.
And you get mascots.
And I didn't test it.
Do the mascots. I don't think they line up.
I mean, maybe.
Not like in real life, but like.
No, I mean, like, I don't think that I saw like a bear and then a weird green alien.
And I don't think that either of those are for New York or L.A.
or anything like that.
Yeah. So no matter what two teams you pick, you're going to get a bear and a frog.
Yeah. Frogs. so later uh this game was north america first which is you know kind of rare for us but
this game being basketball centric was more of you know in line more likely to be an audience
but it is weird that konami's giving it to us you know like a japanese company giving a north
american game first but it would come to um the discard format in japan for the family computer
disk system but they changed the title okay it's no longer double dribble what is it now i want each
of you to give me one guess for uh an exciting basketball name okay i'm going to say uh
traveling traveling okay i like that traveling okay no that that sounds like a uh like a very
introspective like visual novel or something well no you're keeping it in line with the fouls
double dribble now traveling uh slam dunk 87 slam dunk 87 okay um i asked for an exciting basketball
name so what was wrong with exciting basketball that's they changed the title to exciting basketball
you better believe that he's so good uh you better believe that exciting basketball sold okay
given you know given the marketing around it sold okay and uh double dribble also came to
the sega genesis and that's something that we like to talk about too much yeah the sega genesis
probably upgraded some stuff yeah it's 16-bit um it's called double dribble playoff edition
and it allows for eight players eight players at home like so like eight friends can all hook up to
one genesis using a peripheral genesis and they had like and do four on four yeah it was like a
multi-tap essentially i'm trying to think of what the name it's the it's called the sega's team player
adapter peripheral and it lets eight different players play the game wow i think that's awesome
that would have been i mean i feel like that would have been like just like a a mess but yeah i
remember there was always like a i was big on wwf and there was a wrestling game for like sega saturn
called royal rumble and i don't know if you guys know but like i had that for ps1 as well yeah and
royal rumble is like a one where like 30 people enter the ring and like if you leave the ring you're
out and the whole idea was is that this was the first ww again that would let you have eight p eight
people control players in the ring at the same time and it was like whoa like that's really close
to a real royal rumble yeah eight is close to 30 when you're a kid and uh also double dribble keeping
it alive even today double dribble fast break for ios fast break oh i like double dribble fast break
is it does it play similarly yeah it's pretty much it's pretty much double dribble okay you know
um like the nes one it's pretty much that since it's the version most people are familiar with
just updated to have better graphics but yeah mostly the play style is the same and i just think you
can't play that anymore if you have a anything new like if you'd have to buy like an iphone 4
oh really because it's yeah they changed the architecture from 32-bit to 64-bit interesting so
those 32-bit apps don't work anymore and i'm very positive konami wasn't like oh we're not making
many a double dribble fast break anymore better pay someone to fix it wow uh yeah that's actually
a thing that happened so there's all that anybody have stray thoughts um i think that the intro
is a little too long yes you watch all the you watch the whole entire crowd converges on a stadium
in three different directions yeah um and so where is that i don't know what city it's supposed to be in
but i think there's like palm trees but you know it's in the united states of america because okay
they all go in and then you just see some like like you see some fireworks and then some like i guess
like guys on jetpacks or something or something pull up a giant american flag and i'm like i thank you
konami for being very uh very hospitable to the americans that happens every time you go to a
basketball game and nobody sees it because everybody's it only happens after everybody
gets into the stadium you have to remember this is at the height of the cold war and so konami's
just picking a side you know they're just letting us know that you know they're they're standing by
the united states i forgot all about that thank you for bringing that up because i'm just like
it looks like you know this is a reference only for long islanders but like it looks like the
nassau coliseum is where they're going because it's just like it's just the stadium this giant dome
stadium and then a parking lot you know like just a gray empty space of things there's no city
backdrop there's no there's nothing it's like we all just go to the stadium yeah yep and it's sad to
think that that many people showed up to watch me steal the ball from the other team 20 times and then
shoot three pointers did you win like in the 50s was like this going the 50s or was it no i wasn't that
good uh but i i think um when i when i started that game i was losing convincingly yes like 20 to 4
oh not like really not being able and then like as i started learning the tricks from game faq i
started you know convincingly winning the other way see my best game i did something similar but
still didn't win but i i was down by quite a bit and then i kind of kind of all started clicking for
me close okay it was 49 51 49 i lost yeah pretty good not bad all right uh and that brings us over to
the essential games list
nba 2k19 2k20 on the way do you think they'll do 2k20 you don't finally have a reason to change it up
see that this is a question that i had like back when it was starting to get to the teens
like because you could always see that it was a year if it goes like you know nba 08 right because
it doesn't it shouldn't start with that but once you get to like nba 10 i thought that would that
why not um it doesn't make sense now that i think about it but it sounds nice it's kind of like
double dribble right yeah nobody wants to do that you can't actually even do that in this game
there's no way to control how you dribble the ball there should be a button and so for that reason
i'm voting it no no no i thought you could double dribble you can double dribble i don't think you
can do that i don't think so double dribbling is when you have both hands on the ball yeah or if you if
you if you hold the ball and then dribble again i don't know how you do that in this game how did we
no that's different though that's traveling when you okay so double dribbling is uh you
you you're you're going with the ball then you hold it right and you can pivot with it and then you
start and then you start dribbling i'm pretty sure there's a way if you like oh maybe it is maybe you
can only travel in this game wait so there's a way that you can like go to shoot but then either of
those things can i can i get some clarity on what i was thinking traveling is is just walking with the
ball yes but i thought double dribbling was when you just dribble with both hands
you're not allowed to do that right two basketballs but you're not allowed to you're not allowed to
i mean i just don't think it's it's like it's gonna do you any good if you do that
yeah i don't think it's illegal i just think it's stupid wow okay so here i go i'm learning um i actually
surprised you said that and we didn't say i only played uh basketball for one year at the y
and um i was like eight and the coach thought i was so bad that he just told me go home and
practice your dribbling so 500 with each hand there you go that was how i learned how to play basketball
well thanks coach was it essential the the coach the training and the y
inessential i felt bad saying that the y is inessential but like if you need it go to it but
don't abuse it if you don't need it uh if i didn't double dribble in this game i traveled i did one of
those things in this game i don't remember how i don't know how you can do it i think i like went to
shoot but never released or something and then it was like i had held the ball but then i started moving
okay bigger question for you here joe is knowing this gonna affect your vote yes okay 1000 okay so
sean i think you need to remind the viewers at home what the essential games list is now because they're
thinking like this is we're in that segment now we're not talking about voting yeah we we got on a
little bit of a sidetrack but the essential games list is a point in the show where we vote to see if
we want to add a game to the essential games list which you can find at www.nostalgiacast.com
slash essential yes that is the url um and it'll be added to a uh um a cornucopia of great games such
as super mario brothers and others that's all you can remember not castlevania or kid igris or
legend of zelda or somehow i didn't i mean like i figured they'd get the idea but um i get it yep
those are essential games and we're gonna now determine if this adds to it and joe joe well i feel
like you really wanted to go there but um i think that these sports games i think we've said this before
have a little bit of a tougher point of entry like it's hard it's hard for me to vote a sports game
essential because i feel like a lot of them are doing even though we haven't seen a basketball game
another basketball game yet they really build off of each other they do a lot of similar things to
each other um i did i think i like this game maybe a little more than you guys maybe because i didn't
notice the exploits yeah i had a lot of fun i thought it was i thought it was fair with the way i was
playing it um and i thought it was like a really good presentation of it maybe a little a little too
much presentation sometimes but but overall it's it's not like it it didn't blow me away really i
mean i'm not i'm probably not going to go back and play this on my own but you know i don't think
it's a pass sean um yeah i i think that double dribble has a lot of uh of fun to be had um
but the fact that there are these game breaking uh ways to play uh definitely takes away from that
um the fact that it is a sports game more or less like disqualifies this from the essential games list
just because of how those games are um but i'm not saying that didn't have fun like i i like this
game i think it's a little janky but i had fun with it i'd say play this game with friends like
i i liked joe's tip about learning with the cpu and then playing with friends uh that's definitely
recommended if you also have friends who are familiar with this game you're just really gonna
get a stomping if they know how to play this game and you don't but i think this is a game this is a
game that everybody should play just as much as everybody should also play nes golf you know which
is a game that i actually love so i'm not being ironic there but i'm saying like these are games that
clearly have better versions in the future right the basketball has been done better since then
golf has been done better since nes golf but i would still say go back and play those games just
to see how they were done what what was done to them how they went about like using the nes's
limitations to make an nes style version of those games so i think like this is a totally competent
basketball release despite the flaws but the flaws and uh to sean's point the like game breaking
nature of of it like the things you can do to manipulate the game kind of disqualify it
from outright from yeah from being an essential game it's there's no way people are gonna say
like oh if you haven't played double dribble you haven't played video games you know that's just never
gonna be as soon as anyone others so uh for me it's not essential and yeah and that is three no's
and so the search continues for another essential game uh if we had voted it in though that would
have been it that would have been it we would have stopped the search the we're only looking for
one more then we're all gonna go on to a private island and just take those games you know when you're
making off this podcast yes that's what we were doing uh you know with all the money we're gonna
buy our own island are you guys cold yes it's been cold in this room yeah so maybe we should wrap this
up uh you know nostalgia is a podcast it's a website it's a twitter account it has an email
it's a revolution nostalgiacast.com join the revolution it's a revolution yep uh you usually you know
usually uh you know on your walk to the subway or uh you know your walk through town hall uh you
know if you just want to sit in your room and do nothing well i was going on a different route here
sean i was talking about how like on your walks to these places you usually see people handing out
brochures you know like take one of those brochures they're probably from us we you know
we enlisted people to hand out brochures about nostalgia and let people know about the cause
because nostalgia is a revolution it is we are we are working on um the first you know it's like a
gofundme kickstarter hybrid that is gonna work on just having nintendo we're gonna try to buy them
yeah we're trying to buy nintendo buy nintendo and have them just make nes games going forward we're
also release the nes and just make brand new ones we're also searching for a a suitable and electable
candidate to run uh as the first uh nostalgia cast uh party member yeah for for presidency
president um yep we are looking anybody who has ever thought they should be president should uh apply
for this job yeah uh again our emails are contact at nostalgia cast dot com i urge every single one
of you to tell me why you should be the nostalgia president and part of the revolution and actually
the uh the poster boy of the revolution or maybe just why you like double dribble you can also email
and tell us that as well well joe you look like you want to say something or you want to maybe say
that we didn't mean anything we just said no no no i think that's all fine great i got nothing yep
and don't forget we got show notes on the website we got twitter with uh at nostalgia cast where i post
a bunch of images of stupid stuff that relates to video games um stupid stuff uh and also i'm on
twitter i'm michael asito and you can find me on at esposito film on twitter and i'll talk to you soon
you